a la fecha el 16 de junio el lugar
ginebra suiza
joe biden y vladimir putin ya se habían
reunido cuando baiden era vicepresidente
ahora se encontrarán por primera vez
como mandatarios en un momento
especialmente tenso entre los dos países
discutirán las relaciones entre rusia y
eeuu problemas de estabilidad
estratégica y la agenda internacional
incluida la cooperación contra el cob y
bajo esas palabras genéricas se
encuentra una larga agenda para la
reunión los acuerdos de desarme nuclear
pueden ser un punto de encuentro entre
las potencias mientras que la reciente
detención de un periodista en belarús un
país bajo la la de rusia o el conflicto
que sigue abierto en ucrania son temas
de confrontación igual que los recientes
ciberataques contra compañías de
instituciones de eeuu que la casa blanca
achaca moscú
este test no sugerimos que será fácil a
partir de aquí de hecho seguimos
esperando que tendremos conversaciones
difíciles
tendremos confrontaciones en puntos
donde estamos en desacuerdo pero es una
oportunidad para avanzar hacia una
relación con rusia más estable y
predecible una estabilidad que se había
perdido durante la presidencia de donald
trump
el camino hacia la reunión ya fue
allanado por un encuentro entre los
titulares de exteriores de cada país
hace una semana